we've got a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p let's take a
listen to this voicemail that came in
today hi david this is the antelope
calling in i just had a quick thought
was just wondering what you think the
lasting impacts of the the constant well
really you can just call them lies that
have really been emboldened by this
administration and what you think that
will mean for the future
even after trump is gone whether it be
2020 or 2024 yeah thanks i've talked a
little bit about this generally but i
believe that the donald trump presidency
will not only open up the door
potentially to even more outrageously
unqualified and incompetent people to be
elected at different levels of
government but the normalization of a
total lack of diplomacy decorum and sort
of a respectful way of carrying forward
political business is a huge liability
for the united states on the world stage
so the lying is part of it the line is
part of it the making fun of people of
different races people with physical
disability it's all horrible in terms of
the normalization that exists and i am
genuinely concerned about the lying
aspect of it and much more because it
has lowered the bar so significantly
about what is even expected from our
elected officials i just wonder if
future presidents will be able to get
away with the lies that trump has been
able to get away with i mean there is
this whole idea of don being Teflon Don
yeah and I think that applies it does
and I think you might be right that
other people might not get away with
these level this this degree of lying
but it's still normalizing the bigger
picture of yeah listen you just you got
to read between the lines and it's okay
that he's promising things that not only
does he not understand he doesn't even
really have an intention of doing it's
all being normalized and it is
incredibly dangerous we've got a great
bonus show for you today no time to tell
you about it but you can sign up at
david pakman.com slash membership
or patreon.com slash david pakman show
the bonus show happens every day
and it is now world-famous and available
to both members and patrons and will
speak to you that